china's belton road initiative has
scattered almost a trillion dollars into
infrastructure investment across the
globe since 2013. and some of that money
has gone right here in kenya
specifically this nairobi expressway
which just opened in august
the toll highway runs about 27
kilometers through a city with notorious
congestion problems it's cost almost 600
million dollars entirely designed
financed and built using chinese funds
but the bigger project is the railway
the standard gauge railway runs more
than 350 miles from the capital of
nairobi to the keyport town of bombasa
funded by a 5 billion loan from expert
import bank of china a chinese firm had
operated the railway but this year kenya
railways took over the project with the
aim of reducing operating costs by 50
the worry though is that it may not
actually be profitable for some time for
many these projects are welcome
especially in a nation much in need of
infrastructure development there's been
great progress on road infrastructure
across east africa and that's making it
easier for us it's making it cheaper for
us or more cost efficient to deliver
brands across the patch so i would say
the transformation nursing on road
infrastructure is good for business and
money from china has flowed freely
across the continent with fewer strings
attached than funds from the west but
the financial terms of those deals
remain a secret china is kenya's biggest
trading partner three times as big as
the us and in the run-up to the
elections we heard both candidates
stress the fact that china is important
to the economy and will play a part
going forward but that position remains
controversial especially with growing
calls for more transparency about these
deals and growing concern about debt
[Music]